Guys, I just got out of bed,
so I'm not ready for the day yet.
But I come in,
and we named.
We named the starter Giuseppe,
and Giuseppe has had an explosion.
It's. I'm so shocked.
That was only day two.
Like, it's not supposed to rise that much, right?
Like, I've never had this happen
like this big bread right now.
What the heck?
So Giuseppe is for sure alive and.
Oh, okay, Jen,
you're just making a mess now.
But day 3. I haven't even fed him yet.
Look at this.
This is insane.
I'm gonna get ready for the day
and then take care of this,
move him into a bigger jar. And.
This is bizarre to me.
I was smelling it to see if it smells sour.
He doesn't smell sour yet,
but he has all the bubbles,
and he's obviously risen a lot.
So I'm probably gonna feed him today and tomorrow
and then make some bread.
But, you know,
the sooner I can make bread,
the better, in my opinion.
Wild morning to start love day. Good grief.